well we've told you on this show a
couple of times about declining
standards at the FAA part of the wider
war on standards that is gripping the
whole country and against which we will
be fighting starting this week and the
name of diversity the FAA has added an
irrelevant biographical section to its
hiring process for air-traffic
controllers Congress could intervene and
require that hiring be dictated solely
by actual qualifications for air traffic
control
we hope that happens so does congressman
Frank LoBiondo he represents New Jersey
chairs the House subcommittee in
aviation and he joins us now congressman
thanks all for coming out mr. chairman
thanks for having me on so um it's we
got what you already know the data that
show that the FAA intentionally seeks
out unqualified air-traffic controllers
and it's worth fine what we haven't been
able to figure out is who's responsible
for this so first thank you for raising
this again it was your network who first
raised it a couple years ago and gave us
an ability to get some traction but
unfortunately it got left in the day
we're not gonna stop because it's so
important so we were blindsided under
the Obama administration and the FAA
administrator at the time Michael Huerta
normally they come to Congress and say
hey we're going to change the procedures
in this particular case air traffic
control qualifies what how do we do it
what are we going to do nothing just did
it blindsided us when we started asking
questions why did you do it did you
check this by a biographical out to make
sure it was going to work
nothing silence so we've been fighting
this now for a couple of years without
getting any answers any explanation as
to why with a total blind side we had
the Department of Transportation
Inspector General involved we have the
Government Accounting Office involved
and you had a very able guest on Michael
Pearson who's done a great job but
because of the lawsuit both of those
agencies sort of shut down so what was
the most egregious part of this
we've already attempted and addressed
and that is that the CTI students and
that's how this first came to me right
CJ's students are kids who've gone to
school direct
we intentionally become air traffic
control they have the aptitude and they
paid tenants of thousands of dollars to
do this it's amazing and they had the
rug pulled out from under him totally
qualified ready to go into the training
program and told sorry but so what
understood is is there anybody who will
come out and say yes the FAA should seek
out people who are unemployed for three
years in bad at science to become air
traffic controllers well anybody
actually defend that no I died of it so
why shouldn't Congress pass in its
authorization for funding for the FAA a
rule that says you cannot use a relevant
criteria for hiring air traffic
controllers it's too important you're
not allowed to do that can we can we do
that well if I were writing the bill and
we're able to do it without the consent
of the Senate and just do it through our
committee we would do it well who are
the members of Congress would get in the
way of that who would say we need to
hire more unemployed people who are bad
at science well they won't put it that
way they won't put it that way
but you know the way it works the House
passes a bill the Senate passes a bill
it has to go to conference and then you
know the Senators get involved and the
thing gets mucked up but what is
important to know from what you're
reporting do you think that they
understand that wives are at stake these
are air trafficking
I don't think they pay enough attention
to it but what we were able to correct
which I think is important to point out
is that the CTI students and maybe most
egregiously military former military
especially military air traffic
controllers are now into the mix again
no it's good but if there's a single
person who's unqualified and hired for
this job again this is not to become a
gym teacher no it's not these are air
traffic control it is but this is what's
important to also know if one of these
people who really maybe doesn't belong
there gets through the initial process
they have to go through the Academy and
they're washed out because the Academy
will put up with no nonsense I don't
believe that for a second well this is
activist look there are things that are
more important than ability and
everybody in the bureaucracy knows
you're graded on irrelevant criteria
like your commitment to diversity and so
like you're going to have bad people get
through of course it's wrong it's
totally wrong it still congressman thank
you
okay thank you so nuts it's hard to
believe it's real
please keep on it Israel well we're
gonna keep on it okay